scary situation there in the southeast
alley but here at home we have our own
situation going on that's
not scary necessarily but there's some
rain in the mountains and heavy amounts
sasha we're talking possibly up to one
to two inches right now we do have flash
flood warnings
in effect all the way to 6 15. we're
going to definitely track those
conditions and also
earlier we showed you a video thanks to
jessica fortstopper for sharing that she
said
up there things were horrendous and
thank goodness some roads were actually
closed so today we are definitely
heating up back again being above normal
with a high of 1.05
we will continue to stay hot although we
won't be close to that record number of
110 set back in 2011. you could see lows
for tonight 87 degrees and outside right
now
we're still tracking that heat upper 90s
for sky canyon you can see centennial
hills at 96 degrees
north las vegas triple digits for you
and the strip at
97. checking out your regionals right
now we start with red rock at 88 perump
92
boulder city 102 for you and check out
all of this activity all that
thunderstorm activity mainly kicked in
this afternoon and mainly it was for the
higher terrain here in the valley
also for the arizona area which is still
definitely seeing a lot of heavy
flooding there and of course some hail
we're also going to be tracking
more of what's happening for the next
few days not a whole lot of monsoonal
moisture
for the las vegas valley we're actually
tracking southwest flow
and definitely that will bring us some
drier air you're going to notice we do
have the potential to see maybe another
round of rain
mainly for the higher terrain after that
things remain
extremely dry and all of that activity
that we were hoping to get
mainly goes back again to arizona you
can see that they're shaping up for that
thursday as for the windows light
available conditions will remain
but we are looking to get a little bit
of gusty conditions mainly on your
tuesday
mainly in the afternoon gusts can peak
up to 18 miles per hour we will show you
all of the green and blue representing
the gusts that it's looking to come our
way for that tuesday mark
the next few days though heat will be
the primary concern we're still tracking
a high of 108
eventually we will fall to 107 but it
looks like we will be above the
100 degree mark overnight lows here's
what you can expect baby 73 lee canyon
in the 60s perhaps 81
in primp with 74 degrees here in the
valley those lows will be of 86 degrees
mostly clear conditions
and let's start back again showing you
your sally j seven-day forecast where we
have a whole lot of sunshine excuse me
we're also tracking gusty conditions for
tuesday
not as strong in terms of the winds but
definitely a whole lot of heat coming
our way back to you